Senators March out quick feed cross the line
on to the left wing for Shabbat who's joined
the rush here on to kachuck at the point Chan
with a long shot fought off there drop feed here
for bson bson picks it up at Center STS kachu in
front backhanded Elvis makes the save picked up
by tereno back to the point on here to Sanderson
Sanderson in the slot KU League feeds it scramble
in front there Elvis down covers up trying to get
back on his feet another attempt he's down Stacks
the pads without the goal stick here now centers
run this Play That Elbow play down then up to the
middle and into traffic and then that's that puck
scrambles you can see rinsky little trickle the
puck to the pad so doesn't look like it was going
to quite make oh a couple opportunities there but
not without some chaos down low final seconds less
than 15 Elvis still without the stick save rebound
and he covers up here jackets go D to D rinsky
back for boist right back to Zack who jumps up
in the play fires right on Corpus stears that
one aside no question about it again it was a
disciplined Blue Jackets team the other night they
went through the entire game without allowing a
power play here five plus gone and they' now been
short twice and play was whistled down from that
angle there was the referee's angle bouncing Puck
settled down by proov jackets defend in the corner
kachuck trying to dig that puck free out of the
wing kubalik cross ice little more than 30 seconds
left toik into the SL lot little give go oh Elvis
with a big stick save there from Point Blank Range
Chan cannot keep it in Sanderson will rifle it in
less than 30 seconds left on the power play tereno
tried to get to it bounced off the wall knocked
down here by Sanderson able to keep it in tereno
in the corner Urich behind the net melt into the
corner here Senators look up high Joseph Sanderson
quick shot off the goal post with the turnover
jackets get it right back down the right wing
line L's pass broken up by the center here's a
two-on one for Ottawa kachuck looks moving in
and scores the Senators on the odd man Rush we've
seen that so often a turn over in an odd man rush
and the Senators are on the board four feet in
and the opposition's blue line four feet in and
there it's a pass Force to the middle of the ice
you can see the forward that were with line they
trusted that he was going to get that deep they're
up on the other side of it and it's a two-on-one
with the veteran clo jeru and kachuck with an
incredible pass and jaru is a magician in there
in tight you see that fake he's got a toolbox
of fakes and moves and goes across the goal
mou and now P Tilly right into the slot
of back end attempt by Ling nice s back
and the fans here in Columbus appreciate
his effort you mentioned him going against
Elvis M leans who beat him out for that number
one job power play goal and it's two nothing
Senators as fantelli steps out of the box
Brady K's got a massive smile because it's
it's a play that they probably run a number of
times it's just pitch and catch and as Shabbat
freezes everybody in the middle of the ice Brady
kachuck knows what's coming and it's that pass
in the Wheelhouse and he goes shorts side shelf
and you see all this there he had to respect that
Shabbat fake in the middle he can be a shooter
or a passer and that fake froze everyone kinsky
now head up steps to Center back across the line
around the Dasher cut off on the wing L will get
it back L with a r shot scores power play goal
the Blue Jackets are on the board and they've
cut the deficit in half Patrick l it's on the
right side of your screen way at the top of
the Zone it's him and Johnny Goodra up at the
top and they're going to settle things down
and then Patrick l this is what he's got to do he
sees good net front presence always there as boom
Jenner and his buddy yis coroso doesn't pick
up the fast ball as that whistles past him and
this is what Patrick has to do more Jeff just
shoot the puck you know not make look for that
crossy pass be a threat to shoot at all times
and Boon Jenner ch will dump in the all Russian
line here with baronov at Center and he's played
that position previously in the KHL but Branson
for B less than five minutes left over oov left
in the sloted he scores the jacket have tied it
up he gets to
celebrate yeah he made that puck he turned it
over it was a 50/50 puck got Shabbat trying to
find it and baronov says I found it and it looks
like it gets deflected off the backside of the
defenseman for the Ottawa Senators it's just a
quick play towards the net to tie it up one on a
power play Senators had a power play goal of Their
Own by kachu to go up by two oh good work there by
the jackets outworking the Senators player Corpus
Salo now lineing on defense till full stride Adam
fantilli puts the brakes on fantilli into the slot
for Danforth his shot was blocked comes up by here
to jacket Defender and tiied in front it beats
corello and Columbus with their first lead of the
game Adam Fant Tilly on the shot from the point
the big man goes right to the net vantilly does
a nice job with that puck that gives lony the time
to get there he's just standing right in front of
Yas Corpus and here's proov he sees that screen
in front and fan Tilly with nice hands he's quite
a ways away from the net a high TI and there just
enough as corpolo goes down you see he can't see
it it's a late reaction and it's because Patrick
l is not playing on the outside how about that a
one-handed deflection of that just kind of stabs
that stick at the puck David Urich saves it at
the right point on to proov down the left side ROV
circles an that still with it off the goal post L
backing him up looks to the right wing Corner
Jenner sets the screen in front good row left
wing back to rinsky shot scores power play goal
boom Jenner I believe tipped it in front and the
Blue Jackets with backto back Power Play Goals
they're two for two and they now lead by a pair
it's tough for the net Miner Bo Jenner is one of
the best in the league and it he is moving as the
goalie would move just at 3 he's staying right in
the eyes of cor pasalo and how about Zack rinsky
he took a shot moments ago it was hard it was a
pat rinsky shot there he just flicks the wrist
and boom Jen there's no question he works on that
every single day and there and this is why he's
in good position he deflects that puck downwards
and coroso you can see coroso trying to CRA back
l l looking to the point and it's redirected
out to Center race for it here Senators come
this is Joseph walking in rebound covered up by
Elvis M lakans this crowd the fifth line is in it
here great man and he's here on the trip
the father's trip all set we're underway
35 shots oh boy coros Salo goes down awkwardly
cor pasalo was alert he's going to get dumped
in off the glass anytime it's on the glass
you see those metal stanions that can come
off just like that this one was almost perfect
oh a one hopper Pro Rob would have no part of
that grro will clear and that'll do it the
Blue Jackets defeat the Ottawa Senators 42